here we go Thursday
celebrate celebrate means
[Music]
right
it's Thursday
it's Thursday and I want to welcome you
guys to - this past weekend here we are
as Thursday and it is it's February 8th
February 8th you know what happened this
year that I didn't really I didn't paid
much attention to was uh Punxsutawney
Phil and Punxsutawney Phil is a is a
rodent
I mean I'll put it to you like that you
know a lot of people say he's a you know
uh a groundhog and that could be you
know that could be true but also he's a
rodent and he has I guess a disorder
where if he sees his shadow then he goes
back inside and a lot of us have that
disorder that's a mental health disorder
and so I guess that's why he's become
such a hero to everybody because you
know it's one of the first animals that
I know they have a lot of animals that
deal with it but this animal you know
they kind of made a little show out of
it every year or if he has you know a
lot of anxiety then we you know it kind
of it's it creates this idea that we're
gonna have a longer winter you know if
Phil if Phil Punxsutawney Phil has
longer anxiety then we're gonna have a
longer winter and so it's pretty
interesting but I don't even pay
attention this year you know I realize
it's the first year out that I never
paid attention to what was happening
with mr. peepee right there Punxsutawney
Phil I never you know usually I'm keyed
in you know I'll get up early and watch
the UM you know on the internet now they
have this Phil feed and it's just a the
Phil feed is um it's just a feed on the
internet where you can see what you know
how Phil basically how Phil is feeling
and what Phil's feelings are and and
this year I didn't do it and I don't
know if I didn't do it I think it's just
one of those things you kind of evolved
out of
you know you just kind of grow out of it
you know there are things in like their
stages that kind of just you just
evolved out of certain stages and out of
certain things you know you evolve out
of um believing in Santa you know of
course somebody tells you you see
something naughty you know you see
somebody you know you see Santa doing
something nasty or drinking and you're
like this is something you know this is
different than what the books are
telling us you know this is different
than what the commercials are telling us
and you evolve out of that you know
there's uh you know some things there's
things you just kind of quit thinking
about and quit inspecting I guess and
Punxsutawney Phil was one of those for
me it just became one it just became one
of those things where I was like ah you
know I got enough of my own anxiety
enough my own mental issues to tune into
this animal once a year and see what his
issues are and see how he's faring
faring as an animal so I didn't even pay
attention it was February 2nd I'm gonna
look up right now what he even saw you
know punks Punxsutawney Phil and I'm
gonna see what he even saw granddaughter
a is he saw his shadow any it said um
that it's gonna be a colder second half
a the it's gonna be colder than usual
for the next 6 to 8 weeks so there you
go that's it and and they don't have a
lot of animals that converted that can
do that sort of thing but when you read
up on a lot of animals you find out that
they have animals that can do it you
know a lot of sheep and cows and stuff
if it's gonna rain they'll get nervous
you know if there's gonna be a
earthquake then you know chickens a lot
of times we'll try to get to a little
bit higher ground so if you have a box
in your yard and you have some chickens
in your yard if there's gonna be an
earthquake
chickens are likely to try and stand on
that box or jump up onto that box so if
you have a one box
you have you know 60 or 70 chickens
outside and all of a sudden they're all
on that box you know if they're all you
know like a 700 piece like a KFC 700
piece if they all up in there then you
then you can start to expect that
there's going to be an earthquake you
know they also say that a lot of I think
there's other animals horses giraffes
will lay down if there's gonna be like a
volcano I think let me look that up yeah
but it's just um
shoot this internet and I'm working but
yes there's gonna be a volcano if
there's gonna be you know a lot of
animals can predict different stuff and
so it's you know a long time ago when we
were Native Americans before you know we
before we weren't Native Americans and
you know that's one way to put it that
we but you know we were more into that
sort of thing and that's how we knew
information and now this information is
just all out there it's just free
information you can have as much
information as you want now and I'm
starting to wonder are we gonna get to a
place where we don't want it anymore you
know I'd love to I just wish there was
sometimes just a cage where he could go
where there was where you didn't have a
desire to have any information because I
start to see it as an infection
sometimes you know it's just it's just
it's constant reminders of what you
don't have in front of you like I
remember you know when I was young you
know we didn't have everything but we
also didn't we weren't advertised
everything everything wasn't advertised
at us you know I had a cousin glance who
didn't have who didn't grow any hair
till he was probably about maybe 10 and
a half and for a long time people
thought he had cancer people thought he
had you know alopecia people thought he
was you know Mormon people thought all
kinds of stuff because he didn't grow
any hair till he was ten and a half
but the the the main thing with glance
was that he just didn't have it in him
you know his genetics were I don't know
if they were faulty or they were you
know they were factory direct I don't
know what the hell they were aftermarket
or whatever but his genetics didn't have
him hair didn't have him on the hair
clock until 10 and a half years most of
us get hair out of the gate you know we
get hair right when we get into the
world everybody gets a little bit of
hair and you get some hair on your head
or you get some you know babies will get
a little bit of hair all over their body
you know they get a little bit of hair
all over their body and you could it's
damn you know they're just little I mean
they're just little guinea pigs really
they're little guinea pigs really
they're just a little heavy so little
bitty hairs all over them
I'm not sure what it's called but glance
didn't have any hair until he's probably
ten and a half and I remember people
were praying for his hair and you know
praying for growth and but it wasn't in
the cards for him but he also like he
wasn't you know we didn't have all the
information out there at the time where
you just didn't you know you know
everybody there was tons of information
as to why he didn't there wasn't
constant there wasn't constant there
wasn't constant advertisements for hair
companies you know and hair Mart or you
know hair net or different places were
all kinds of places you know propecia
all this you know cuz if that would have
been the case then you'd have had a kid
you'd have had my cousin who was you
know who would have spent his whole life
trying to get this this hair trying to
get this thing instead of living his
life you know and that just feel like
with all the information now we're just
there's so many options there's so much
you could be doing this or what you're
doing isn't the best thing you could be
doing and as long as that carrot is
always out in front of me I don't know
if I can enjoy the salad that I meet
if you know what I'm saying here and I'm
vegging here I'm using vegetable ideas
but it's like how you know as long as
that as long as that carrots dangling
out in front of me how can I enjoy you
know the bounty that I have in front of
me and it's hard and I think that's one
of the pitfalls of information and of
advertising these days is that it's just
well it's not a pitfall of advertising
minutes it's it's a it's it's there I
mean advertising kind of our
arch-nemesis really if we want peace you
know but of Technology and information
it's just it just it's constant reminder
of what you aren't doing or what you
could be doing better or you know now
it's like say you you know you go and
look up a recipe for eggs you're gonna
make an egg salad or you're gonna make
just regular eggs without salad fried
eggs you know we're just to gather eggs
scrambled and but now you go and look up
a recipe you have the recipe right
that's all you wanted to do but then you
know now maybe you make your eggs and
then you're gonna watch a video on on
the Internet but now the video knows
that you just looked up eggs the
Internet does and so now it's sending
you all this other stuff better than
eggs they have a recipe called better
than eggs you're like [ __ ] now you would
you're just try you just spent time
making these eggs and now you're eating
eggs under the in the shadow of an
advertisement for something called
better than eggs and is it better the
next who knows what the [ __ ] it is you
know who knows but it's it's just that
that this information always looms it's
like this you know it's like that I
don't know it's just always right there
in front of us and I just miss the days
when that wasn't it when everything was
just more more chill more calm where you
enjoy it you know you you know you get
what you're getting you don't throw a
fit
because you didn't have a fit to throw
because you didn't know the other
options man I remember you know when I
was young you were just happy to have
whatever and the only goal when you were
a child when I was young was not to get
you ass beat by your mother or your
father
I remember this boy you that one of the
Yuva kids had his family that lived down
the street from us called the Uvas and
this one boy stuck I don't know what his
full name was Stanislaus or something I
think they were from they might have
been Dutch I mean I don't know if they
were Dutch or not there were pieces of
[ __ ] but they might have been you know
dutch [ __ ] but they the Uvas had this
one of the boys stuck he'd had his um
and it's a nick that was a nickname
Stanislaus I think was his real name but
he had his fingers glued together two of
his fingers and I mean you know not just
a line of superglue I'm talking a whole
damn you know one of those green bottles
with the red cap they'd really put it on
him and he had to I mean he was just a
ding you know a we blow Scout all the
time he had that double up you know and
he couldn't get him off never got him
separated as long as I knew him which is
probably nine years and so he would
always suckle on his fingers you know
and he would just enjoy that glue enjoy
that hit you know and I don't know where
this story was going were we talking
about over took him on when you oh so
one time he stayed over so one time
stuck stayed the night at my place my
mother's house that I lived in when I
was a child because we all live together
cuz we're a family and and this is when
we were still a family when we were
still you know all living together he
and and my and and we and so our big
thing was sneak down at night makes you
know cook some [ __ ] in the oven some
basic ass [ __ ] crackers you know maybe a
little bit of cheese on maybe a little
bit of um you know [ __ ] just bop him
up with that American slice you know
maybe take a slice of American and cut
it in a four
bam bam you know put them crackers you
know get him you know throw a little
pepper on them [ __ ] you know fire him
up and we get that oven heated get that
oven you know crank but you know the
light from the kitchen it could hit the
under the doorway about my mother's room
and if I made too much noise she could
hear us so you didn't want mom to hear
us and you wanted to get that food made
and one of the most amazing things I
ever saw was one time we had the oven
open right and the UEFA's were one of
the toughest families I've ever met in
my life
one of them had I mean this kid might
have had damn two spines in his back and
something happened to his teeth it all
grew in on one side of his mouth it was
just one huge tooth I mean this tooth
was probably two and a half inches long
and when that thing broke through his
gums I mean I can't even imagine when he
was teething as a child you know the
rest of us have to have ointment and gel
and you know get novocaine shot up just
for sprouting a couple little enamel
nuggets you know a couple little goat
little a couple little baby ghosts and
here he had this two and a half inch
grim reaper rolling out of his gum
asphere into his you know into his mouth
and it was can't even imagine but anyhow
anyhow we're making these you know we're
making these cookies you know we firing
up these hitters down there with these
crackers and cheese a little bit of
pepper
maybe some you know whatever else may be
mixing up a candidate orange juice they
used to have that orange juice it was
like this that is frozen chunk in the
freezer and you got that chunk at first
you would take it add this tight white
plastic cord around the can and a can
was freezing cold
they can't had ice on the outside the
can didn't want you getting inside of it
like cans nowadays it's got these easy
peel tops and you know it makes like a
when you open something not the cans we
grew up with those frozen [ __ ] orange
juice may you add if you end up doing
you added you know I mean you had a
[ __ ] sit there and babysit that thing
you had a sweet talk
it was frozen you could barely hold on
to it and it had frozen orange juice
inside of it and I don't even think it
was real orange juice it was just orange
[ __ ] ice but it was a huge chunk of
it and so the thing was to get that ice
out and get it into a thing of water
then you beat it around this jug of
water with a wooden spoon and then you
got you don't really have orange juice
but what you have is sort of a lightly
or you have kind of orange e looking
water with a huge chunk of kind of
orange stuff in it in the pitcher so
anyhow means so many how me and stuck
come down make that right then we start
getting ah we're getting these hitters
that we put together we slippin them in
into the oven and these had no gray
block hit us you know these are basic
run-of-the-mill [ __ ] 4th Ward
Covington Lousiana out there off Lee
Road you know back there by the bailed
hay dealership right down from ozone
field you know right there where they
got all the animal carcasses out in a
ditch this is those hitters you know
this is more these backwoods hitters
that we made you know it's the cracker
them saltines got that American cheese
that little hit of frickin that square
okay so you know the shadiest cheese too
you can see through it a little bit
you're like oh this [ __ ] looks
questionable it's not even taste like
cheese it just tastes kind of like
yellow it tastes like a little like like
uh it tastes like um like harsh yellow
and then you got that pepper boy we
douse these [ __ ] up with pepper right
so we put it to tray of him in the oven
quiet quiet quiet don't wake my mother
right don't and my mother was a kind of
lady that laid in bed waiting to get
[ __ ] woken up I don't even think she
went to sleep I think she just closed
your eyes and waited to beat someone and
I'll tell you that's the toughest thing
I ever seen happen out of somebody I
don't know what happened we're in the
dark we get the oven open we get the
thing stuck false
on to the oven door open oven door
blazing hot I mean this thing had been
preheated we only preheated things to
400 we only burned [ __ ] in my house
nothing was ever cooked correctly it was
either [ __ ] burnt because here's what
happened you put it in 400 was the only
thing we knew you put it in a 400 then
you forgot about it and then you smelled
smoke and you ran downstairs and then
you got your ass beaten and that was how
we cooked in our house but stuck fell on
this hot door with no t-shirt no shirt
on his back and he held it in it was
dark in the kitchen and I could see the
pain on his face when stuck you've a hit
that hot door with his probably 11 or 12
year old skin and held that pain inside
of him it was just a different time and
now you go upstairs you google you do
all kinds of you probably call the
police on your parents all of this all
of that man I remember just you know we
put him on his stomach we laid the cold
towel was on him put put the towels we
had some towels that were some spare
towels and we we put these towels into
water into cold water and laid him on
his back but man it looks scary his back
bubbled up
I mean look like the it looked like just
like his whole back look like a top of a
meat loaf kind of and then you know it's
just a different time though you know it
was just a different time when things
were different that's all I'm saying
it was a different time when things were
different and I miss it a little bit and
stuck had a brother and and this was an
older brother could have been an uncle
and that's the kind of the family it was
you know it was sort of that
you know I mean the you know the DNA
kind of did what it did you know I'm not
everybody's got that you know that
family tree you know some people got
that family cactus and there's a fern
hanging off of it over here and you got
a couple of [ __ ] you know you got an
owl living in one of the branches and
he's you know selling selling coke but
you had a he had a brother that had
moles on his back right and this moles
these different moles and moles are
little pieces of cancer or whatever that
live in your body sometimes they try and
get you get or not cancer but they're
basically they're basically like the
devil's little death buttons and they
might have cancer in a minute and if the
devil presses them and pushes that
cancer in your skin then you can get
sick but sometimes the devil just leaves
them on your body and you just dancing
around with these fancy little you know
benign and malignant studs you know you
up there stunting and flexing with these
studs aren't you and and that's what
happened with with the oldest Yuva
brother he had tattoos he had all kind
of tattoos he had tattoos and one of
them was a constellation of his moles he
had made a constellation and I don't
want to say it was a Ryan's belt it
could have been a little dipper and we
only knew like three constellations back
then but those were the days man those
were the days Munez didn't have this
this wasn't so much information out
there you know and I think um you know
over time things like that evolved out
you know when I was young those things
were fun those were like the people in
my neighborhood and those were you know
and we played football every every day
we play football if it didn't rain we
played football then we played in the
street we played in the street man did I
saw this kid one time got his head run
ran his face right into an open mailbox
open mailbox one of the black lenses you
know this hardy ones the metal ones
now everybody's got a plastic mailbox
they don't want their mail to get hurt
when it gets delivered but we had the
metal and I saw this boy get his face
stuck right in it had to go get to
people's dads to come out and help him
get to get his mailbox out the get his
face out the mailbox and those were the
times man and the kids were tough and
things were different man and it was
just different and so I don't know I
guess there's Punxsutawney Phil things
just got me kind of reminiscing in some
of my past and just thinking about some
things and just thinking about things
that evolved out of my life you know and
Here I am you know I'm an adult and I'm
sitting here and it's like you know it's
just different now you know I was
talking to somebody the other day I was
having dinner or an early dinner with
some friends and we were talking about
work and she was saying how children
these days and some of you listeners may
know about this I don't I've never
thought about this before because I was
saying I was telling her how upset that
I feel and how lost I feel and how
disappointed I feel that there is so
much technology now and that we're
getting away from our feelings and
interaction as humans and connection you
know real human connection and she was
telling me that children these days you
know because I'm generation I don't know
what I am X or something or I don't
think I'm why I think Y is I won't say Y
is women and I could be wrong but I'm
like now it's Generation Z I believe but
these these kids there's no difference
for from like just having a feeling like
like like a digital feeling is the same
as an actual feeling like it's the same
thing that like if they love someone if
they express that love on you know by
liking something or sending a heart or a
certain series of emojis that that's
that's
that's to them it's just as real as as
if whenever we were kids and we you know
told somebody we cared about him or we
did something fun with someone or we
expressed whatever feelings the emojis
express whatever feeling we got as we
did that as we express those actual
feelings those actual emotions because
emoji just comes it's just you know
little shapes that represent actual
emotions but that that for children
these days that there's no difference
and she was telling me that that the
reason and and she wasn't like I know it
all she was just you know this is
something as she had read or she had
heard it a speech I think she said that
the reason that people my age I'm 37
have so much trouble dealing with some
of this stuff is because we were we've
been alive to see both and that's why
there's such a disconnection that's why
we feel so uncertain that's why the
technology sometimes feels so scary
because it's you know we knew the
original form of it it's like whenever
somebody brought you know a typewriter
to a man that that wrote with a with a
quill with a feather in ink that first
I'm sure that man was like would this is
you this is that you can't really put
your feelings into a typewriter and then
here we are and you know and we had our
original emotions and now you have
someone coming along or you have a time
coming along where you know when kids
were born and they knew about a
typewriter they never thought about the
pay they thought the pan in the and the
ink were ridiculous you know basically a
per a bird pervert so she was just
saying that and some of your parents
might know if you have a you know if you
if you recognize that that it seems the
same because I'd never thought that
instead of being like oh [ __ ] like we're
the human species is ruined is it just
more that the humans
species has evolved and now we express
our emotions those you know digitally
and they still represent the same actual
feelings to us as they did when we
express them actually you know with
actual emotions so I don't know that's
it I had never heard that you know it
was just it was super interesting to
hear cuz I hadn't heard that but yeah I
guess you know it's just a you know it's
a different time it's a different time
but I want to thank you guys for being
here with me on this past Thursday we
got some calls that came in I'm going to
Portland I'm going to Portland this
weekend I was this - hi dang I'm going
to Portland this weekend so if anybody
have any a friend in Portland I'm gonna
be at Harveys in Portland so if you have
any ideas about it or want to have a
friend to come out let them come on out
also I had someone I had a young lady
submit some artwork for the dark arts
tour and if anybody else wants to do
that submit artwork for the dark arts
tour I'm trying to put the tour together
right now
please do and that my email is th e OV e
o NK at ma si.com and that's th e OV e
om k @ ma c-calm and that's that dark
art store and one idea that i had that
was pretty cool was like the doom the
doom poster you know the do they have
this doom poster where the guy is like
fending off a bunch of aliens but if we
could make a way where those aliens are
are the dark arts and whatever the dark
arts are are resemble to you and we have
a couple of pieces of stuff coming along
there and I may use the stuff that this
young ladies sent in I need to email her
back and discuss it with her we also
have a great new shirt idea that's come
in from one of our listeners and I'm
super grateful so I just want to say
thank you guys to that next week I'm
shooting a couple of digital episodes
for
central with a show that's actually
based on the podcast so I want to thank
you guys so much for the support that's
going to be cool there'll be some some
unique comedians that you know that will
be in it and it's really the premise is
you know young men and women who are
going through certain things they call
up and we try to find unique ways to
help quell and you know help take the
burn out of them you know that help take
the burn out of their skin and you know
with whatever their problem is help put
a little bit of salve on them if you
will but I'll be at Harveys in Portland
and that is this weekend 8th through
11th I'm also gonna meet up with the
hamster rancher and that will be going
to go on the patreon page for a week or
so and then we will put that on to
regular YouTube but I'm excited to meet
up with him in Portland thank you guys
for your support on patreon gonna be
able to hire a camera person just be
there and help out with that la jolla
I'll be at the Comedy Store February
16th 17th and 18th February 23rd and
24th I'll be in in do the fantasy
Springs Casino and then Tacoma 15th and
16th the March will be up there and
we're gonna try to get a tricky long
Mickey a date and then October 23rd and
24th I'll be at levity live in Oxnard so
those are some cool things that are
going on thank you guys for your support
last week we had this call that came in
[Music]
and it was it was this guy right here
this is James from Omaha Nebraska and
I'm calling because I've got a little
bit of Dark Arts on my mind so on and we
all do James and if you feel that
heaviness if you feel something that
starts to this just just nibble if you
feel behind your ears is these bone
disease lumps about but sometimes you
can feel this this cloudy little
darkness start to just nibble on those
and that is usually the
our cards but onward I'm 21 years old I
have a girlfriend who have been dating
for about three years now it's a pretty
serious relationship
that's that três anos you got that trace
on yo saw that trace on you is crotch
you know that três anos chica and that's
beautiful you know three years with
anything is good these days a lot of
animals don't even live three years you
know but homework I just see myself
being with her the rest of my life but
you know there's this thing on my mind
where you see I lost my virginity to her
I've never been sexually with another
woman before the same is not it's not
the same for her she did not lose her
virginity to me if she hooked up with
several guys before she met me okay and
I'm just gonna cut James's collar for
deckers we are the call was in on the
from the Monday's episode and so and
what this episode is about is about the
responses and one of the things that
well let's get into some of you guys
responses real quick and then I'll talk
a little bit more about it because I've
already been talking a lot or not a lot
but some you know I mean [ __ ] well I'm
the only person in the room so of course
I'm gonna be talking but uh but anyhow
alright let's listen to a response or
two hey this is Abby the friendzone girl
and I have a some advice for James all
right Thank You Abby and Abby rep
talking about the friendzone she had
called in a while back about how to get
out of the friendzone and and people had
called and given her some thoughts and
ideas onward I think from my perspective
it is rough here on these web streets so
if you've got the one and it's just to
get even just leave it alone and that's
a good point
is it just to get even you know is that
what's like you know I and you have to
figure out what your intention is there
James like and sometimes it's hard to
figure out your intention because the
intention can mask itself it could be a
true desire to meet others it could be a
fear of commitment
it could be revenge and I'm not saying
that any of those are definite or
necessarily wrong when it comes to love
because the love is and love is it love
is a dirty dirty little dancer and
Louisville [ __ ] just dance all up in
you all opinion written in your brain
it'll just it'll it'll Rhonda's um down
your neck and it'll plie across here
across your scapula's and it'll climb up
in you ass and karate kick you in the :
love is a dangerous dangerous thing it's
a very dangerous thing it's caused Wars
it's caused families I mean it's caused
beauty it's caused triumph I mean love
has done everything love has been the
catalyst for ever I mean it hasn't been
the catalyst for everything but there's
nothing that there's nothing that love
hasn't been the catalyst for let's hear
more on the other hand if this is
something that's going to bother him and
cling to him then get it out your system
because you don't want to be married
just have kids and then still want to do
this and then talk up your whole life in
your relationship because you had
possibly one night because you never
showed your oats so I mean like you said
it is not pretty
just having belt hookups and everything
I mean it's just not worth it if you got
a good one you keep it and there you go
and that's a B and so that's nice and a
B thank you very much for calling and
that's a you know it's a nice side that
female perspective because a lot of us
men we're dogs James we want to see out
there in them streets you know you know
knocking on going door to door and
busting into some Chrissa you know and
hitting it you know hitting that low-key
waterslide you feel me you know doing a
couple of you know doing a couple of
laps in the old shallow end so we want
to see that but that's man stuff and
then you have a be calling him right
there with that thought let's take
another call
pretending to this here we go heyo this
is Christian calling in from Ireland a
Christian from Ireland that's awesome
man I love Ireland bro I love Ireland
and I love Scotland and I love Scotland
let's hear more thank you for calling
Christian just thought I'd call in about
your mind James the golden Oreo yes the
golden Oreo and that's a man that's only
had a relationship with one woman Oh
word there's a Nutter Butter girlfriend
I mean that's an I think I think it's so
I think it's a beautiful thing that he
is you know madly in love with this girl
and as you said it's young love bro um
21 is so young and I think you could get
that tunnel vision as well and you can
like see that or feel like you're gonna
be with this person forever but you just
don't know you just never know
Wow and I'm just pausing that thank you
for your for your thoughts there
Christian we really do appreciate and I
appreciate everybody's calls yeah it's
like 21 is so young well first of all
doesn't it sound so much fancier being
in love in Ireland like it sounds like
real love over there doesn't it he's
like are you ready you know you love
your lady oh you know sorry I'm doing a
bad I'm doing a bad I'm not making funny
to Christian I'm just trying to do an
impersonation
it sounds more I don't know the the
American tongue is just I think we're
just so tired of hearing it as a planet
is so tired of here which is so much
American voice then when you hear
something you hear that [ __ ] you know
that that Scotch riddled fiddle of a
throat that the Irish possess then you
hear that you know you hear that just
the just the Bourbon II baritone beer
filled barrels of of barf aged brisket
and
just murder and rain and murder and
stuff like that man when you hear that
out of the Irish tone it just everything
seems more real you know you seems like
love over there is something real
whereas in America just you know become
a couple of people just probably even
not even sharing a bed and just jerking
off near each other or touching
themselves let's hear more thank you for
calling Christian what's around the
corner
it's amazing how quick feelings can
change too and I don't know I think you
shouldn't worry about it too much like
try not to look too far into the future
and just exist in the moment just exist
and enjoy what he has Wow a couple of
great points there man you know that 21
is so young unless you die early and of
course that's a crazy caveat because
odds are you're not gonna and I
shouldn't even have said that man I'm
sorry but I was just had a weird stuff
going on in my head this past month but
you know 21 is so young dude if I would
have married the girl that I was in love
with at 19 oh my god I would have killed
either me or her if I would have married
the girl that I was in love with at 24
25 actually it might have worked out
with her it might have worked out with
her okay you know there was still like
um oh if I was also in love with a girl
at 21 Shh I don't think I could have
handled that to be married to her she
was a great girl but I couldn't handle
that you know some women change as they
get a little bit older like a little bit
different but but when I look back I'm
like oh I couldn't have done it and not
to say that they could have dealt with
me either you know I'm no you know I'm
no peppermint Pat I'm no peppermint Pat
but you know when I look back on my
cough I'm often grateful and I'm not
trying to send you in a certain
direction James but but Kristen is
saying is that it can change so mate you
know if something is in there's some
uncertainty or
just because you're so young you might
want to keep some of those options open
let's hear what I want to hear your all
your your into your call one more time
Christian you just don't know you just
never know what's around the corner
it's amazing how quick feelings can
change too and I don't know I think you
shouldn't worry about it too much like
trying not to look too far into the
future and just exist in the moment and
there you go and that's it just stay
where you know just stay in a moment yes
have plans we're seeing each other this
is going okay and you know ride the
horse until the horse loses its limbs
you know ride the horse until the horse
loses its limbs because you know I'll
say this there is something beautiful to
about being in that young love man you
love is the best when you are young it's
like so it's like sex is the best when
you're sex is for children is sober sex
sober sex is for children if you're an
adult having sober sex no you are
something's astray because there's just
something oh I remember being in love
and I was young did you go see your girl
and you're just so excited to just [ __ ]
later you you you're so excited to [ __ ]
you can't even hear the other person
when they're talking I'm a raw data this
one girl for like eight months I never
heard a word she said cuz all of my
blood was in my penis bro all my blood
was trying to get was trying to coerce
semen out of my nuts my blood was like
hey we just built your penis into a
bridge semen don't you want to fly
across the bridge out into the world MA
so there's something also beautiful
James about staying in that young love
and just basking in it and bat stroking
in that [ __ ] I mean dude you could do
yeah youth is there's just so many gifts
you could kill somebody James
you can kill someone now you know em I
can't kill somebody it's gonna put a
huge dent in my career path it's too
late you can kill somebody get off for
second or you know maybe second-degree
not premeditated you could be out in
eight years think about that you're not
even 30 yet and you've what you've
gotten rid of somebody you don't like
and you still have a great opportunity
to like there's just a lot of
opportunities for you all right let's go
to another call here hey Theo this is
Jacob from Oklahoma hey Jake thank you
for calling man and Oklahoma is a
beautiful state and I've spent some time
there in Oklahoma we went to a water
slide there in Oklahoma City me and some
friends of mine went to a water park and
we found a missing child there and we
bought him a sandwich and then
eventually some people came and picked
him up so he wasn't missing let's hear
more I've called for your golden Oreo
boy James two ways to look at the
situation James number one if it is
gonna bother you then you might as well
get out now like if it's something
you're not going to be able to get over
just her laying more pipe than an oil
company and you're not having any of it
I would bounce out now because that is
something that if 10 years down the road
you're just going to end up cheating on
or something like that if it's just
boiling up inside it yeah
number two the relationships are hard to
come by and sex is something that is
adaptable so if your your relationship
with her can grow your sex with her can
grow but it might be difficult for you
to find another relationship and there
you go you know I heard this week
somebody said you know when you settle
down you marry the relationship you
don't really marry the person and I'm
not saying I agree with that
but it was interesting to hear that that
you know some of these other things
they're accoutrement
they will fade you know a lot of it
fades and in the end you you you just
have two people and what are they alike
what do they like when they're around
each
they're so you know there's some there's
some thoughts right there from Jake if
you're feeling about getting out of it
then get on out of it you know get out
now but there's some beautiful things
that can happen you know and sometimes
it is hard to find a relationship that
other things are adaptable let's hear
another call here hi CEO this is Megan
calling for James I know you asked for
male advice but maybe I thought it
helped to have some female advice from
someone who has had typically more
sexual partners than any of the males
that I have been encounter with dang
Megan Vinh out there we got matin Megan
right here she'd been out there matin
thank you for calling Megan let's hear
more but James would be does she please
you sexually is it something that you
aren't fully satisfied with if not maybe
have a conversation with her I know a
lot of males have a hard time ant I mean
obviously females to have a hard time
expressing what it is that they even
want when they're in bed if you have
been together for three years and you
guys are comfortable this is someone you
see yourself with being forever then you
guys should be able to have that kind of
conversation like look I don't know what
I really liked you are the only person
that I've been with but maybe we can try
some new things mmm man that is a tough
come for me that's a really tough
conversation to have I mean I don't know
if I could ever tell a woman the things
that I like sexually that sounds scary
to me
and I and obviously I know when as I say
that and I've thought about this before
that's something there's something
inside of me that you know just prevents
me from feeling comfortable sharing that
I mean I can be trying to be a pervert
for sure you know I'll try to touch ass
you know you know I might try to hide
something in your booty you know you
know we're tight you know or tie you up
outside you know or tie both of us up
not just you but but at the same time
you know I'm afraid to have that guy to
with us woman that I care about to have
that converse
Asian oh I think it just scares me this
makes you feel like it's just a dirty
person I guess you know for me for me ha
but let's hear more Megan maybe she's
even open-minded enough to allowing you
to try and be with someone else sexually
it isn't it's not about love I think
we're all animals at the end of the day
and we all are here to have sex I don't
see there being any harm in that Wow and
that's true dude I've had these uh when
I was growing up they had to what were
those I guess they were dachshund maybe
I don't know what is it dachshund but
they had two dogs about us that were
pretty much husband and wife for dogs
you know always saw them together they
had kids everything and then one of them
though the man I would see him [ __ ]
this other dog down the street sometimes
or at least a half a block away
he didn't go super far because he seemed
like kind of a lazy animal to me but I
would see him [ __ ] this other dog and
then why his wife or the other dachshund
never really kind of turned a blind eye
to it
and I know that's using animals as an
example just as Megan just you know
inferred that we were animals but that
that's true if you can you know maybe a
lot of this is communication if you can
communicate with your lady jameson that
you got them desires to get out there
and pump and skeet skeet then maybe
she'll let you maybe she'll be partisan
to something like that because you know
what is fascinating to me I think I
think half of the relationships that
haven't worked out in my lifetime
marriages half of the marriages that
haven't worked out in my lifetime would
have worked out if the couple could
agree on some okay infidelity and to not
label it as infidelity but but to let
there be some stray every now and then
let somebody catch up hitter that
strange you know let somebody catch a
little bit of that duck duck mmm whoo I
see locally if they have to every now
and then that duck duck goose you know
cuz you duck and duck and every now and
then you want that goose let's hear a
little bit more from Meghan so maybe
she's open-minded enough to that just
it's worth the conversation whoo and
James I'll commend you if you can have
that conversation you're a man bro but
I'll tell you know as to some of the
points that have been made I hate to say
it but I think that there's more than
just one true love out there for people
and when I when I lived back at home and
you know in a smaller town and you know
I don't know if I felt it as much
because there weren't as many people
there wasn't one of those many
opportunities and you know people that I
run across but I think that you know you
can fall in true love more than once now
that doesn't mean it's gonna happen for
you I mean I have some friends who have
gotten up into their 60s or men that I
know who have just never found true love
and now maybe they're not good at
detecting it maybe they're not good at
knowing what it is but for whatever it
was for them you know it never it never
passed it never came by let's hear
another call UFT oh this is Trevor
calling out of Moscow Russia
I'm calling for James oh I didn't know
this is from Moscow Trevor thank you for
calling and this is our second foreign
call today Ireland Russia coming in with
some white-hot heat right here and we're
not trying to not keep things diverse
but we apparently we had some you know
predominantly white countries that
called up let's hear more wiedersehen
and then golden oriole I just wanted to
let him know that I'm in the same
situation as him Wow and there you go
that's some of the magic you share other
people share what
more but seven years later so I'm hoping
that I could give him some words of
encouragement and like some reassurance
so okay and so Trevor is saying that
he's seven years he had the same problem
seven years ago onward the most
important thing to realize here is that
a relationship after the college years
doesn't really revolve around [ __ ] as
much as people want you to believe I
know maybe he's listening to Daliya
who's telling him to not be in a
relationship go out [ __ ] chicks every
night and stuff like that but I mean in
reality dude you got to realize that
you're going to be focusing on your
career you're going to be focusing on
like maybe travel and hobbies you're
gonna be [ __ ] glad that you're not
the one doing the dishes at night so
instead of worrying about going getting
some crazy chick and [ __ ] her you're
gonna be its grateful that you're not
[ __ ] washing dishes dude and your
wife's cooking for you or something okay
so I'm a little confused because you're
saying that he's he's gonna be grateful
that he's not out chasing strange chicks
and that he's not washing dishes but the
truth is that if you're not out
Streisand if you're not out straight um
if you're not out chasing strange women
then you're probably gonna be washing
dishes
you're probably gonna be at the house
with your lady but yeah there's some
schools of thought out there it's just
like stay out there and [ __ ] but I'll
tell you from experience and that it
gets empty it gets addictive because it
gets hard to fill they gets hard to fill
that void you know cuz you just you know
a lot of times you're just uncomfortable
because you're lonely and so then you
take that loneliness and you'll hook up
with another girl and you'll just create
more loneliness you know I mean I've had
the you know the fortune over the years
of be I've you know been with some i've
been with some ladies you know and i've
been with some real ladies and one lady
i even was with ended up getting sexual
transmission trans engine and is now a
man so i've been on you know I've done
some things you know but I was I was
there at the starting line not at the
finish
with that gal and I'll say it gets
addictive and it gets lonely and there's
at a certain point there's nothing out
here for you you know you're just out
here for your own ego filling up your
own empty ego and it's crazy cuz you're
filling it up but also you're making the
void bigger at the same time now with
that said daddy likes to fricken get a
lady night you know and eat that eat
that cookie you know and snack that
cooter pie so I like to do some of that
and I'm not saying it you know but I'm
saying you know I don't know what I'm
saying let's hear a little more from
Trevor here there's something so if you
have these dark guard thoughts in your
head maybe just bust a nut get those tea
levels back down and normal and then
you'll be able to reassess reassess the
situation and Trevor and this Russian
Trevor talking about busting nuts there
and it's pretty amazing that we have a
show here where a man can call up and
recommend to another man that that he
bust nuts and it not be sexual I mean
that is pretty that's pretty rare I
think you know you just don't get that
every day these days you mean you just
you just don't get that all right let's
take let me see if I have any final
thoughts on that for James you know
James if you're ready to start a family
if you if you see that this woman is
gonna be you know you're not looking
around you're locked in then I think you
go for it I think you stick with your
girl maybe you give it a beat you know
maybe you don't make any crazy moves
with her for a year if you're having
some of these reservations maybe you
talk to her about some of the
reservations you are having maybe
to help put some of them out of your
mind maybe she's open to the threesome
thing I mean one thing that's kind of
scary out out here these days is that is
that there's so many options you know it
goes back to the information thing
there's so much I mean you can know
every woman that's on your street now
before in the old days when you were
like it you know in the 40s or something
I don't even know when it was sometime
you'd be at this fruit shop or at the
grocery and you'd see some other woman
you probably sold to other women a month
just randomly outside of your wife and
you just saw one at the store squeezing
a melon and you just came in your pants
immediately and that was just and that's
how it was that was all that was the
Internet was hoping that some lady with
clean hands or maybe even dirty hands
back then who cared decided to test the
ripeness of a piece of fruit in the
vicinity of your eyes and just as she
gave it that you gave it that you gave
it that dried up call you know they are
there's a website somewhere where they
recorded the sounds of men ejaculate and
they play you can hear the sounds
amplify them and the most popular one I
sort of heard was that it's a little bit
of a you know like a mallard with a
toothache kind of like a like that it's
interesting almost it almost sounds like
a you know has something like almost
like an astronaut kind of you know
walking into the or not not even like an
astronaut really anyhow good luck out
there James that information is hard you
it's an uphill battle I think it's an
uphill battle for any man because I
don't know if we were I don't know if we
were made to to battle this and maybe
the younger generation won't have to
battle this as much
maybe that's just something that we're
doing you know like I was mentioning
earlier maybe that's just since you know
people my age are in that transition
where we had a childhood that had none
of this and then we have an adulthood
that has so much of it now we're the
ones who were so conflicted and so torn
and so but but that our children in the
end that generations you know beyond us
are going to it's just going to be
natural that now our emotions are just
digital emotions and they're just as
real it could be and also that could be
crazy it could be that you know 30 years
from now we're all sitting somewhere and
have a virtual reality universe where
we're out there and maybe not third
maybe 30 years where whatever job you
have you now go to it just fictionally
and you know we're all drinking these
smoothies that keep us alive and I don't
know and some way it's wild it's a lot
I'm getting to a couple of calls here
real quick I want to thank our charter
sponsor and you know that is that's
great block pizza and their link will be
at the bottom of the story in the
information gray block pizza 18:11 Pico
Boulevard if you on your way to the
beach and you thinking oh I know what'll
go good but this sunny day and your
friends like um chocolate you like no
[ __ ] great block pizza stop on
in get that on Monday's episode we're
gonna talk about I don't want to tell
you yeah we're gonna talk about if I'll
tell you but I just don't want a bunch
of calls about it because I want I want
us to you know - I'm gonna have callers
talk about it after we're gonna talk
about if there was a war amongst all the
states who would win and why it's gonna
be almost like a little bit of like a
March Madness kind of thing and that'll
be on Monday's episode we still got some
calls were going through here I
appreciate everybody's calls in for
James
and James I you know I really applaud
you for calling that's a real question
you know I remember when I was your age
us I mean I couldn't be honest with a
girlfriend I remember I cheated on all
my I only had two three and I cheated on
them you know I just didn't you know
part of me I wanted I wanted love so
much you know I wanted to have that
connection you know I wanted to have
that I had that you know I maybe not I
wanted love but I wanted that I wanted
that family I wanted that idea of like
you marry your childhood sweetheart and
this sort of thing and you get you know
in one of you gets a job and you come
home with a briefcase and there's a dog
and he's you know hiding a bone in the
yard and and you go inside and you know
two-year kids are doing homework and one
of your kids is blind you know and is
sitting by the fire you know and you
spend time with all your kids and you
love them all the same you know I wanted
that kind of perfect life that you would
see on TV or that you but I didn't not
to love anybody I mean I in my in my
soul of souls I had so little faith that
love and that you know familial
connection and that those things were
real I had so little faith that a woman
would actually take care of me and care
about me and I couldn't even tell that I
that I was scared about those things I
didn't know I just now looking back I
see my reaction the way that I behaved
that that at that time those were some
of my biggest fears and also because now
I know this that those are so my biggest
fears you know it's really tough for me
when it gets in a you know a situation
with a lady you know to catch that
intimacy you know it's easier if you out
here with these strays you know yeah
here you know [ __ ] people out in the
wilderness or meeting somebody by a
national park you know and that sort of
thing or somebody about a bar or
something like that somebody at a
crosswalk or somebody who's a you know
of age and all that
so you know it I mean I can't even them
James if you go through it that I can't
imagine I mean you would be the brave
you'd be the Clint Eastwood of
relationships I think I don't look
there's anybody else in America doing
what you're doing but then I don't know
I don't know what these young kids are
like these days you know I don't know
some of you guys may know I do not know
at all let's hit a couple more calls
that came in here we go it feel
my name is Tyler I'm from Wisconsin
what's up Tyler that's cheese I said
queso country up there and that's a home
of um Brendan Dassey and he's from you
know he's from that making a murderer
thing and they accused him of killing uh
being a part of partisan to that killing
and when that documentary came out dude
I got on the internet and I contacted as
many people as I could that were in that
documentary and at one time I was
emailing three people in that
documentary just discussing things with
him there was that beautiful reporter
this levy I think Sondra levy no sound
relieved he got murdered I think I don't
remember her name but I asked her out on
a date on Twitter and she rejected me
and she was a reporter in that in that
documentary anyway
Tyler onward and I got some half-assed
burgers man a lot of Dark Arts coming in
and it's amazing that this is a flick so
many people's lives it's amazing and uh
and we're gonna come out with some dope
Dark Arts gear and stuff this year just
just t-shirts and some cool posters I'll
be hitting out this year homeward so
Christmas the weekend before Christmas
I'm sitting with my girl in bed or
watching TV watching Netflix and you
know and I was gonna knock on my door
yeah well I think it's gonna be my
neighbor
you thought you the crazy guy he's
always on a smaller you don't hang up
for a second I wanted to be door well
okay so it's a week before Christmas
that doorbell rings and you think it's a
crazy neighbor cuz he's whacked out and
you said he might be on something he
might be on them uppers or something
with him sideways errs let
you're more well I answered the door
just three cops sitting there come on
hey yeah we see your girlfriend's car
out there she dude they go yeah and it
David doors for you okay so the cops
want to talk to your lady more well [ __ ]
apparently she went nuts was on the
either none and robbed a bar which is
pretty [ __ ] up and didn't even tell me
about it I'm just honestly a good thing
cuz the biggest [ __ ] you know finish
it on me if I knew about it so I'm glad
she was kind of secretive about it
anyway that is true man most women they
tell you everything they did with this
gal you know she Rob's a bar and she
keeps that on the DL I mean she sounds
like a keeper
James you might want to talk to Tyler
about how to meet the correct woman
homeward over that and then now she's
back out of the who scoffs she's trying
to get back with me I do like her that
[ __ ] lover man we've been the guys
are locking up for years and I'm not
really sure what to do dude you know and
I think this just this all can kind of
flow in with the James conversation
Tyler thank you for your for your for
your ringing us up there and I'm sorry
that your girlfriend's doing crime and
that she's you know hanging out at the
house while you you know but that's a
cold move dude she's just watching
Netflix
she's just tuned into a little bit of
hose arc knowing that she got you know
uh that she got things pending in the
distance that's ice-cold man it's almost
truly beautiful but here's the thing is
what I'm saying is that things are
constantly going to come along James in
your relationship
and whether it's you know you get your
girl pregnant or you guys get married or
your girlfriend you know commits a crime
and you know tries to you know just kind
of shrug it off there's constantly going
to be times where you can
make a choice and some people it's a
daily choice when they wake up you know
and it's not can I love my wife or can I
love my girlfriend forever sometimes
it's just can I love my girlfriend today
do I commit to her today and that's all
you have to do and that kind of puts it
back into um in a Christians idea you
know just stay in the in this moment
because you really don't know I mean you
could be divorced and out there having
sex in ten years you could be married
forever and be happy as could be you
could be married for two years and
occasionally have a threesome and she
falls in love with the woman you guys
meet you know life is going to continue
to happen no matter what little plans
and railroad track we lay down life's
gonna continue to locomote wherever it
wants to go and the best we can do is
try not to get too set in our ways but
but back to Tyler I think the thing
Tyler is that you know that your lady it
sounds like and I think that's sexy you
know a lot of these women nowadays you
know a lot of these rich people they get
out of trouble said easy there bra ain't
even going to town ain't even going to
jail for anything when you get some of
these real natural ladies being down
there and they you know these ladies
been in and out of the hoosegow and they
got barrettes in their hair still even
though they're an adult you know and
they still have a damn stick a slim jim
every now and then and ain't afraid to
go to a Valentine dinner at Jimmy John
and Jimmy John sandwiches no bite get
some of them they leaving bike the
sandwiches over to you so I say you
stick with that girl sounds like you got
a ride-or-die and if y'all ever shoot
something up make sure it's a Denny's
brother gang gang all right guys I uh I
gotta get I gotta get
I'm gonna throw this one call in here
that came in from big Chuck right here
let's take this one yo what up bo this
is big Chuck calling from NorCal but
actually live in Rio
howdy offer here de Janiero for huh but
I do and I don't know what he said it
sounded like he got his uh you know like
his mouth stuck on something like he's
playing one of those new board games
where you put the thing in your mouth
and you talk at the same time but thank
you for calling bud
homeward going back to Brazil going to
the airport in a couple hours just
wanted to call and say you know man I
hear the I hear people calling in I hear
a lot of people suffering here a lot of
people you know a lot of guys looking
for direction and should I just want to
say to people look look for what makes
you have to use this to you and go for
it you know and if you love somebody
showing you love them don't be afraid to
do that you know gotta be a soldier you
gotta keep doing it gotta keep plowing
forward much love brother much loved all
the listeners oh and there you go and
that's big Chuck and he's headed back to
Brazil and you know did you know that um
Sal Paulo Brazil has one of the largest
contingencies of Japanese people in the
whole world outside of Japan
second-largest interesting but you
didn't know that a lot of people didn't
I think I thank you for calling Chuck
and maybe that's just a good place to
leave things you know Tyler whether your
girl's been running around you know she
got a little bit of gunplay or whatever
you know at least she already gots
handcuffs you know bring them things
back into the bedroom you know and and
James you know you don't know what
follow your heart man
I'll say this James you sound like a
dude that has a big heart and follow
that thing and life is gonna be scary
sometimes you're gonna think I remember
crying outside of a woman's apartment
when I was young and I remember petting
that girl's cat and I talked about that
a lot on here but I remember petting
that girl's cat hitchhiking to South
Carolina and hiding all my
ex-girlfriends porch and a cat comes up
that I don't know because I just got in
a town
and I don't never I've never even seen
this cat or even been in this town and
this cat is sitting right there by and I
just start petting it as I'm crying
outside on this porch stalking an
ex-girlfriend so you just don't know
what what awaits in front of you you
don't know the magic that's out there
for you
James but I think communication is key
so many times if I gotta go back in time
I would just communicate honestly you
know there's something sometimes there's
something wrong in us where we're just
so afraid to communicate honestly and I
think it's because it's sometime in our
life you know we were honest and and
somebody didn't you know respect it or
somebody didn't believe it and I believe
that for myself a lot you know that I
think there was times in my life when I
was just honest maybe even as just a
child or something and and it just
wasn't recognized around me that I was
being real that I you know that I
sincerely was having a tough time and
those things carry in you as an adult
and James if you don't have that if you
don't have that infection of dishonesty
then I say you you just be honest with
your girl
you be honest with her man you know I
heard somebody actually tell me earlier
today I've never been honest and had
things go wrong ever not one single time
now is that true I don't [ __ ] know
barely even know that dude who said it
but it sounds like it could be I
appreciate everybody's calls thank you
guys for hitting the hotline nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
on Monday's episode I'm going to talk
about if I'm out talk about my weekend
I'm going up to Portland I'll talk about
that I mean a visit that hamster rancher
but I'm also gonna talk about if if all
the states separated and there were a
war amongst them all who do you think
would take home first second and third
place but I don't want any calls on that
we'll take calls on it next week I'm
just letting you guys know what I'm
gonna be talking about I'm gonna thank
Spencer Jacob growl for sending in his
music we got a lot of new fan music that
has come in I want to thank you guys for
that
I'll see you in Portland you can grab an
onward this past weekend t-shirt at Theo
von comm slash store as well my boy
Simon Rex and Mickey Avalon are out on
tour they're coming to Iowa I know that
so you guys can go check them out
they're gonna be out and about see if
they're near you and what else that's it
man
you guys be good to yourselves you
probably deserve it
I got am I'm going to edit this thing
and and pack up for my flight to
Portland I'm so excited to be at Harveys
this weekend and that's it I think
that's it
[Music]
celebrate ms
celebrate our days got to be a soldier
out here you got to keep trudging
got to keep trudging whatever it is keep
you head up guys and ladies